hello steve kaufman here and today i
want to talk a little bit about rosetta
stone
now of course you know that uh being
involved with link um
i'm not going to
be totally objective
in evaluating rosetta stone i'll admit
that right up front
uh or at least i think it's fair to
assume that i'm not being objective
so let me say that
i have never tried rosetta stone my son
mark who's of course working with us
here at link who's basically the
the the the
person who has designed the system i
mean it's it those are his ideas his
concepts how we organize the site the
components of it and how he's working to
improve it that's all his work but
before he ever got involved with link he
was a professional hockey player in
japan
his team gave him rosetta stone to learn
japanese
so mark did have a fair amount of
experience with rosetta stone he didn't
like it he found it boring and not very
effective
i did some research on the internet and
i went and found a bunch of reviews of
rosetta stone
um
not surprisingly many of them are by
people who are in some way connected
with rosetta stone so
the first thing to say about rosetta
stone is that they are tremendously
and successful marketing organization
and i give them full marks for this
they have increased the awareness
amongst people that they can learn
languages that learning a language
doesn't require you
uh to go to a school
they've increased the interest in
language learning in all languages
because they are they have rosetta stone
for for every for lots of different
languages so they've done a tremendous
job i think there are great it's great
for language learning
uh so i you know i just think it's great
but uh i posted it on my blog the
linguist on language
uh what i consider to be the sort of
essence at least my understanding of
rosetta stone which is that they have
these multiple choice questions and i i
could read it here it's what one person
said about rosetta stone that the most
important component of the rosetta stone
staff software method
is the four squares screen
the user is presented with a page that
shows four pictures of various objects
or entities a pre-recorded phrase or
word is played back the user must click
on the square that contains a visual
answer blah blah blah
why does this work because it's very
instant feedback instant gratification
people are encouraged and they keep
studying
and of course the biggest thing in
anything is you have to stay with it
so rosetta stone tends to make people
want to continue studying if that's the
case that's great because obviously
people if they enjoy what they're doing
they're going to continue doing it
and i've said and as i have said many
times people are often discouraged in
traditional language classes
the reviewer goes on to say that in
normal language situations we don't get
positive feedback
there is a great deal of uncertainty
we perceive that we're doing poorly
we perceive that we're not
having success and therefore people quit
so you know that's perhaps not a fair
description of everything that happens
in rosetta stone but but based on that
description
and based on what i have heard from my
son mark
i have seven reasons why i am not very
interested in doing rosetta stone
uh i don't put there the eighth reason
which is because of my involvement with
link but the first thing is i don't like
sitting there and answering multiple
choice questions to me that is not a
natural i'm not communicating and as i
said in my book that i wrote some six
years ago
language learning should be about
communicating right from the beginning
if i'm listening to a real story i'm
communicating i'm communicating with the
language with the culture with some
situation so just identifying pictures
on a screen to me is not something that
i would like to do i don't think i would
do it very long
the second thing is that my main
language learning activity takes place
during what i call dead time
i mostly listen seventy percent of my
activity is listening listening while
jogging while doing the dishes while
driving while waiting in line i always
have my little ipod with me
so if i had to if my language learning
activity had to be committed time i.e
sitting in front of a computer screen
i don't think i would do very much i
just wouldn't find the time
the third thing is
that the idea to me that you can learn
these words and phrases here is red
green blue yellow
click on the right one there's a house a
car a horse
i
don't think that i learn words i mean i
i i think i forget them all
i learned them i forget them i learned
how i forget them i don't think i can
nail them down this week i'm going to
learn
house car horse
train then i'm gonna click through
tree flower green and yellow i don't
think i will retain them i know that i'm
learning words because the stuff that
i'm listening to
i'm understanding more and more of it
but at the same time i know i'm
forgetting words because very simple
words after a year i'll have forgotten
the most simple word so i know i learn
and forget
so i don't believe in learning things
that way nailing down things by you know
multiple choice questions
number four you know to the extent that
i learn words and phrases i find that i
have to learn them
as part of episodes stories larger
contexts
where i have tried like living language
and other systems like that where they
give you these phrases i can't remember
them
you can tell me at i was with some
people the other night some brazilians
they told me the name of this brazilian
drink they must have told me five times
what it was karambah or something i
don't know what it was i can't remember
it
but i can remember words in a larger
context where i remember that there was
a story and and these are stories that i
listen to and i even remember where i
was listening to it i was listening to
it while i was uh jogging in uh
somewhere whatever
so so i need the episode i need the
context
the next thing number five is in terms
of gratification
yeah getting something right on the
screen it might be fun for a while but
to me the big gratification
is when i start to be able to tell when
words begin and end
so that it's no longer just noise and
soon after that i actually start to make
sense of what i'm listening to initially
twenty percent thirty percent and sixty
percent and remember when i begin a
language i listen to stuff over and over
and over again
so that to me is the gratification
uh
identifying
house car
knowing that i'm going to forget it
anyway unless i see it in many many
different contexts meaningful context
that wouldn't be very gratifying to me
number six
you know my whole goal in learning
languages is to communicate
communication begins with understanding
understanding a real language and then
being able to express myself in real
situations and i know that that's a long
road i have the impression that rosetta
stone doesn't take me very far along
that road
so i'd be reluctant to get started and
the seventh thing second seventh and
final thing is
that even in terms of getting started
like some people say and i accept that
some people want to start with pimsleur
some people want to start with michelle
thomas
i have started languages with teach
yourself
with colloquial and these are all good
and they have the role and i would
prefer all of those as a method of
getting started because their language
their real language
i'm in a hurry to get into real language
to engage with the language real
situations
so
i don't so i want to listen to things
uh and read and improve you know work on
my vocabulary knowing that i'm going to
forget and learn forget and learn and
gradually the picture becomes clearer so
to me
a little bit of uncertainty at the
beginning
it doesn't bother me and the challenge
is to to sort of eventually
uh get to where you're you're noticeably
uh you know things are clearer and
clearer the fog is lifting the
uncertainty is becoming less so the
uncertainty doesn't uncertainty doesn't
bother me
so those were basically the seven points
i've posted about this on my blog
i want to hear from people who use
ling uh what do you call it there
rosetta stone
and i know that there are people who
love it and there are people who love
link there are people who love michelle
thomas there are people who love rsi so
there's all kinds of people out there i
want to hear from people who have used
rosetta stone who either like it or
don't like it or whatever so these are
just my views and i must admit
that that you can totally discard my
views if you want
a because i haven't used rosetta stone
myself
and b because i'm obviously prejudiced
because i would prefer people to like
link
but i don't really care i want to hear
from people who have used rosetta stone
whether they like it or or whether they
don't
so thank you for listening